Okay, hopefully you realized that in this particular
situation, we're back to four possible genotypic combinations in
our gametes. Having genes far enough apart on
the same chromosome allows alleles to be mixed and
matched in such a way that we can
get those missing combinations that we wouldn't have gotten
otherwise if the genes were so close together
that they appeared linked. Just so you guys know,
if you've had any trouble understanding this. This is one
of the most difficult concepts to understand as a beginner. But
it is also one of the most difficult concepts to
teach. So if you have trouble understanding this, it's probably all
my fault. And, what I'd really like for you to
do is go to the forums and chat with some of
your fellow classmates. See what you've seen posted there. I'm going
to try to put some helpful links in the instructor's notes.
Most of recombination is not something that we
really need a lot of for the rest of
the class, other than understanding the importance of recombination
and how it provides genetic diversity. But if you
have any interest in understanding it better or knowing
more, please there are so many great resources out
there to help understand this. It is an amazing
phenomenon in biology and really is an evolutionary marvel.